truck wiggle out jump run somebody
scared I know I'm gonna be there in your
head talking to you the whole time
shock wiggle out Carolyn the truck slows
down somebody we are Jack listen to me
this is our chance
thank you for letting us do this
interview we're grateful to hear your
story thank you to everyone who's and
their good thoughts and their prayers
for five years you made life in that
small room that prison as nurturing and
normal as you could and you know we're
gonna do today what we are going to bake
a birthday cake you chose to tell Jack
that room was the whole world that there
was nothing else morning good morning
sink I wanted him to feel safe from that
it was a great place for him to live did
you ever think you would be free I hoped
go Jack thanks for saving her look girl
I mean another planet same one just a
different spot sweeping in the world 37
hours of us we push I some windows and
hundreds of cars and birds in cramming
grandpa yeah someone here like me here
huh Hoshi friend us no you will never
find us everyone keeps asking Oh
can you have no idea what's going on my
bow try me
then every time you look at me that's
all you see when I look at you joy I
will see my daughter
you're gonna love it Wow
you